[Music]
Hello everybody. Uh my name is Ima. I'm
a program man uh product manager at
Microsoft. It's a pleasure to talk to
you today about Foundry local which
enables developers to easily build up
crossplatform applications powered by
local AI. So let's get started. Uh the
first question is if the cloud AI is so
powerful why do we need local AI?
So here are four key reasons based on
our conversations and observations with
our customers. So first of all, how does
cloud AI work in environments with low
network bandwidth or even offline
access? Many of you have experienced the
bad internet during this conference,
right? And a common sentence we have
heard from many speakers with live demo
is oh finger crossed hopefully the Wi-Fi
connection is good. So it's not the
effort it's required by cloud AI but
it's not a concern at all for my session
because my lab demo runs entirely
locally. So reason number two privacy
and security. Many companies work with
very sensitive data uh such as legal
document and patient information. They
need to process that data uh entirely
locally without anything ever leaving
device, right? And reason number three,
cost efficiency. Um think about uh game
applications uh which is deployed to
millions of devices with hundreds of
millions inference call every day is not
just sustainable
and the reason number three real time
latency so many AI applications needs to
respond in real time and it's not just
not possible if we wait on cloud. So
that's why we need a local AI. Then the
next question whether local AI is ready
now.
So thanks uh thanks to the decades of
progress in computing hardware has
become more and more powerful. So many
client devices are equipped with modern
GPUs, MPUs capable of running advanced
AI models. Meanwhile, model companies
are keeping publishing more and more
models which are leaner, faster, more
optimized for local inference such as uh
five for mill and uh deepse variance and
we are also seeing more and more
advanced uh state of art optimization
techniques introduced at runtime level.
So this convergence
now makes the local AI a reality.
Then how do we build up the solution?
So Microsoft already has many great
assets. uh Azure AI foundry introduced
um last year at Microsoft Eagleite uh
has been trusted by over 70,000
organizations with over 1,900
models and the Onyx runtime our
crossplatform high performance ondevice
inference engine now seeing over 10
million downloads per month and our
customers are pretty happy with the
significant and uh performance
acceleration provided by onyx runtime
compared to PyTorch.
And lastly, let's not forget Windows.
The scale and the reach of Windows on
client devices are massive. So when we
think about democratizing AI, um the
millions of um you know devices uh and
millions of customers using Windows
devices really matter to us.
So we are not starting from scratch. We
are bringing all those advanced assets
into foundry local an optimized end to
end solution for Simless ondevice AI.
So at the bottom as you can see it use
onyx runtime to accelerate a performance
across various camps of hardware. on the
top uh we are introducing a new foundry
local management service which host and
manage model on your uh divi client
device. It also connects to Azure AI
foundry to download open-source models
on demand.
And for user experience, we provide a
Foundry local CLI which allows you
easily explore models on device. And we
also provides SDK so that developers can
easily uh integrate Foundry local into
your own applications from cloud to
local from different hardware. So,
Boundary Local was officially announced
just one month ago at Microsoft Builder
Conference. It's available on both
Windows and Mac OS. On the Windows, it
is integrated into the platform which
makes the experience even simpler for
Windows AI developer.
As I just mentioned on Foundry local
accelerator performance across different
cans of sicon, we have been closely
working with hardware vendors including
Nvidia, Intel, AMD, Qualcomm to
integrate their hardware accelerators
into Foundry Local ensuring the
bestin-class performance that you can
get on their hardware.
So before our official announcement uh
over 100 customers joined our private
pre preview they have shared a valuable
feedback on how easy Foundry Local is to
use and how good the performance it is.
So let's hear some of their feedback.
Hey there, Savo here, CEO and co-founder
at Pieces, where we've been on an
ambitious journey to give developers
artificial long-term memory across the
OS. Now, offline first AI is core to
this vision and in late 2022, we began
to explore small language models running
at the edge on all major platforms. But
between rolling our own Llama C++ and
then to Olama, frustrations around
versioning, performance, and enduser
experience still remained. That was
until our recent partnership with
Microsoft on their new foundry local
platform, an end-to-end AI inference
solution that offers ease of use and
high performance across different
hardware. In no time, our team went from
documentation access to a
productionready build with noticeable
improvements in memory management, time
to first token, and tokens per second.
If you're looking to deploy ondevice
models, you can't go wrong with Foundry
Local.
We have been working on AI projects for
our customers for several years now.
Some clients want to use the latest AI
technologies but are restricted from
using external services when the
information they want to process
contains sensitive data. Foundry local
is a perfect solution for these
scenarios as it allows us to easily run
Genai models locally. Here we can see a
solution that combines Foundry Local
with a speechto text service. Hello, my
name is Maria Rodriguez. My savings
account number is 1 2 3 4 5 6
which also runs locally. One aspect we
were really impressed by was the
simplicity of the installation and the
ease of using the models. With Foundry
Local, we can now create hybrid
solutions where part of the solution can
be run locally.
It's been a privilege to work with these
customers to improve Foundry Local
together.
All right, I've talked enough who wants
to see live demos.
Okay. Uh let's do that. Um
[Music]
so first of all we can uh let's see our
CLI experience. So on Windows platform
you can um install Foundry local package
using wingget and on Mac OS u you can
use homebrew commands. Um so I have
already installed foundry local. So,
so first uh we want to see what models
supported by Foundry local. So, we can
type Foundry
model list.
So as you can see it supports many
popular uh generative AI models and for
each model you can get uh you can get
different varants optimized for
different hardware. So uh you can see we
have uh optimization version for CPU for
CUDA for integrated GPU. Uh we also
provides MPU variance because um my
device doesn't contain CCON MPU so that
variance doesn't show up.
Okay. So we want to run some models
right and um if you haven't downloaded
the model uh for before the foundry
local will download the model from the
cloud and then run the model u it
requires internet but I have already
pre-install pre-download the model so we
don't need that uh so we're going to see
what model I have already downloaded
using foundry
cache next
so as you can see I have download four
models here. So I want to like during
our experiments I want we might want to
explore different models to see um the
quality to see the performance then
decide which model we want to use to
build up our application. Right? So
firstly um I want to try foundry
model run
2.5 1 1.5 billion model
since I have already download this
model. So the model loading is pretty
quick. Uh should be uh pretty quick.
Okay. Uh the model is set up. You can
talk to the model directly. So let's uh
ask a simple question. What was our next
runtime?
Oh, it's pretty quick, right? Um so I
think uh we may want to see the
latency level. So let's uh exhibit here
and rerun it with
sorry
robos mode
and same question.
Okay so here we get around 90 tokens per
second. Um we also want to try a
different model. So let's do that. Um, I
want to try
Foundry
model.
Um, this 54 mini
also with
smoke.
So, it's loading the model.
Okay, model is set up. Same question was
all legs
long time. So 5 for mill is um more
advanced than like Cuban model. The
model size is um bigger than the Cuban
model. So uh I would say in terms of the
performance it is a bit smaller than Q
model but uh in terms of the quality as
you can see 54 mini uh can provide more
detailed information.
Uh all right so uh personally uh I vote
um 54 mini. So I want to use this model
to build up an application. So what
application do we want to build? Uh I
guess many of you have such experience.
your team move to a new organization
needed to ramp up the existing project
very quickly and there are many long
detailed document documents uh you
needed to read and it's very time
consuming to read every words right so
you might want some highlevel summarized
version of about this project so you can
quickly ramp up and but this project is
an internal project you cannot upload
all those documents to cloud And
meanwhile you have you know some of your
team members are using Windows some of
your team members are using mic. So you
want to build a application
crossplatform
powered by local AI. So let's do that.
So I have this application setting up.
Um so what it does um so we can run it
first.
Um, and let's quick the existing
conversation.
All right. Um, so the app is setting up.
Basically, it is used to summarize
content. Uh, you can give it your URL or
you give the local file. So it can do
summarization and it also has a setting
tab. You can choose the model you want
to run. Uh as mentioned before I preo
for me. So because I want to get some
more detailed information. So uh we can
put uh this model ID
here.
Then uh I will pass it with our project
document
and let it to give me some highle
information.
So I will hit summarization.
So as you can see the summar summarized
version is coming out and uh it says
foundry local is useful to build up
crossplatform AI applications that run
directly on device. That's pretty cool.
And uh then let's take a look at the
code quickly. So as you can see uh we in
terms of SDK we um provide Python SDK
and the JavaScript uh JavaScript a uh
SDK. So here we use a JavaScript one. So
we create the foundry local manager and
uh we
and we initial this manager.
Um second what I say.
Yeah. So initial the manager with the
model name. Um so as you can see I
passed the 54 mini here and then um it
use u boundary local endpoint to create
a client and then you just wait for the
chat to u be complete to be completed
and output the result. So um this is the
application u running on windows. Uh I
some of one team member is using Mac so
I want um he to use on my app as well.
So I package the whole project and share
to him and let's see what his experience
is.
He take the project and record a demo
for me. So as you can see the exactly
same code and uh he just u use the same
command npm run start to start this um
application and exactly UI executive
application and oh he choose Q model. Um
maybe he like this model more and he
also use the same document uh documents
I used uh in my previous demo and hit
summarize button.
So uh as we uh see in the previous demo
uh cubin model is kind of provide more
brief information um than five for mini
model. So as you can see here it also
shows the summarization is more like
shorter than what 54 mini provides.
Okay. So we build up crossplatform
applications. Um is that all my demo? Of
course not. We forgot one important
thing agent right. So everybody talks
about agent. So we so do I. So boundary
local enables you to easily create and
build and run a local agent using local
model and MCP servers. Um this feature
is still in private preview but I want
to give you a sleep um give you a quick
uh look so you know uh how it works. So
let's back to our uh cmd. So uh we can
in uh use foundry agent
list
to show all the available agents uh in a
foundry local. As you can see we have
built up three sample agents here. So in
terms of the concept an agent in a
foundry local consists of one model and
one or more MCP servers based on your
need. So you can use um one model from
the list and pick up whatever MCP server
you like to create your own agent. But
here uh we want to run the existing one.
So I'm interested in this OCR agent. So
uh let's see uh foundry
agent info uh to know what it can do.
Okay. So it can extract the text from
images in your local device and this
agent um contains one model which is 5
for mini my favorite one and the two MCP
servers. One is file system MCP server
one OCR mini MCP server. So let's run
this uh agent Foundry agent run.
So this command will u check the
dependencies of this agent first. If um
the dependency hasn't been installed
before, it will uh installed with your
permission. So I have already installed
all those uh dependencies. So uh it just
run. Okay, the agent is setting up. Uh
it ask for permission to use this MCP
server. So let's say yes.
and he asked a directory you want it to
access. Uh I give it
um the demo folder and he also ask a
permission for the OCR MCP server. I
will say yes.
So all right. So it from here you can
get all the tools supported by this
agent. So literally the tools um
provided in the MCP servers. So you can
get some tools related to file system
tools related to OCR. So uh what we want
it to do so here
is the use query. I want it to find my
receipt um process it and get the total
amount from it.
So let's see uh whether it can complete
this task or not. So it starts to
thinking because it needs to figure out
which tool to use. Okay. Uh the first
tool to use is search file because it he
it needs to find the receipt and then uh
he figured to use the um
after search it use the OCR one to uh
extract the text and then get the output
get the total amount. Okay, that's cool.
So that's all my demo. Um so finally I
know it's a little bit over time but I
just quickly ramp up. So foundry local
enables you to build up applications
powered by local AI and uh one best
practice um so local model generally are
not uh c uh not that capable uh as cloud
model. So um you cannot expect it to do
the fancy work that cloud model or cloud
agent can do but it has unlock a lot of
potential. So I leave that to you guys
to explore. Uh if you want to get more
information, uh here's the link and you
want to uh try out our agent feature,
you can sign up our, you know, uh
private preview form. All right. Uh
thanks everyone.
[Music]